students head back to class a new book
challenges colleges to better prepare
young people for life after they
graduate the cuddling of the American
mind how good intentions and bad ideas
are setting up a generation for failure
says the book says many teens and young
adults are unprepared for the real world
authors Greg lukianov and Jonathan Hite
that's height not hate right in the book
many university students are learning to
think in distorted ways and this
increases their likelihood of becoming
fragile anxious and easily hurt they
join us at the table welcome to both of
you
John I want to start with you failure is
good for learning which I have just done
your book is about making wise people
not just people of achievement
how has the system gotten it wrong so my
first book was called the happiness
hypothesis it was about the
psychological wisdom of the Ancients the
ancients understood how to thrive how to
get along with people and so they gave
us principles like what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger but we have somehow
begun teaching kids that what doesn't
kill them might make them weaker we need
to protect them from words and things
like that which is was Greg's original
insight the second grade on truth is
always trust your feelings and the third
is life is a battle between good people
and evil people well I hope they'll be
able to talk about here about how these
bad ideas got into the educational
system into our child-rearing that's
right let's talk about always trust your
feelings aren't we Ray's Greg do you
know follow your heart pay attention to
your feelings keep in tune with your gut
so I'm always thinking you're supposed
to trust your feelings you say listen
sometimes your feelings mislead you
exactly the grant roots of emotional
reading the reasoning is the one that
sounds the nicest it sounds the warmest
and fuzzy is the most romantic but I
learned the hard way through really
terrible bouts of depression that
sometimes your mind is telling you
things that aren't so nice and that you
shouldn't be listening to like like like
that well you know the common cognitive
distortions as they call them in CBT are
like saying you're broken or if this
date doesn't go well I'm done for or
this job interview fails that I I'll
never get a job again Astrid after
fising CBT being cognitive behavioral
therapy which
in the book you offer solutions about
how to encounter the world and it
requires things like cognitive
behavioral therapy and mindfulness to be
able to be prepare yourself for the
basically frictions of life well that's
right so one of the greatest ideas it
from every culture is that there's
nothing good or bad but thinking makes
it so
is how Shakespeare put it our life is
the creation of our minds is how Buddha
put it and so as students are coming
into a new situation should they
interpret everything as dangerous
threatening and aggressive or should
they interpret it as as a cornucopia of
full of opportunities and there are
going to be there gonna be little bumps
along the way they're gonna be
unpleasantness is should they interpret
those as a tax or as full-power errors
and so how students learn to frame
things will greatly affect whether they
thrive or whether they retreat into a
shell in a defensive crouch in college I
think one of us alarming things for
parents too is we go back to school
everybody's going off to university is
what you write about that adolescent
anxiety and depression are unlike
anything seen in modern times so how
have campuses and schools changed as a
result of that and that's the scariest
revelation for us and doing the research
for it is that you know our argument is
essentially we have anxious depressed
and polarized students and we're
wondering how we got there and our point
is that we're teaching the mental habits
of anxious depressed and polarized
people so Lisa d'amour who's a
psychologist here that's on our show
frequently is writing a book about this
- sometimes anxiety and stress are good
things work they are natural protectants
why have we labeled them as such
negative feelings that then become
all-encompassing well good intentions I
mean the subtitle of our book is how
good intentions and bad ideas are
setting up a generation for failure we
all want to protect our kids and as
societies have fewer and fewer children
and as the as the safety of those
children goes up and up and up we find
smaller and smaller things to worry
about one of my favorite lines is
prepare the children for the road not
the road for the child yes right yeah
you write about the callout culture and
the hecklers veto we've seen recently
The New Yorker invited Steve Banta to
come speak for The New Yorker ideas The
Economist did the same thing the New
Yorker disinvited Bannen The Economist
said you got to meet people who disagree
with you in order to learn which seems
in keeping with your book how do you
sort those two choices well
it definitely would you know our context
is campus and campuses are completely
different institutions that the
magazines and when and when a campus
makes a decision that you're no longer
invited to this campus because we don't
like your ideas that's antithetical to
the whole idea of what a university is
supposed to be well you also have an
interesting anecdote - about peanut
butter we I know I know just lay that
out there as a tease because we are out
of time but a good reason to buy the
book protect your kids from peanuts
they're more likely to have peanut
allergies you say you say parents let
your kids have a couple of bumps it's
okay it's okay
absolutely well Greg Fukien off and
Jonathan Hite thank you so much for
joining us there's a lot of good
questions in this the coddling of the
American mind is on sale now